i do whatever the hell i want and for a
long time i didn't feel like i could do
whatever the hell i want i felt like i
was
a prison to schedules and touring and
you know this and that and that it was
nothing was ever good enough like i
remember being a kid
in my godmother's attic and saying oh
man
if i could just go on tour i'd sleep in
the back of a minivan dude like i would
you know i'd play for free man it
wouldn't matter and i did that
and then i was like all right i kind of
need to make some money
and then you make and then you make a
little bit of money and you're like i
need more
i need more fans and you get more fans
and then you're like man i
if i could just sell the [ __ ] roxy in
la 500 people that's it i made it i did
it and then you sell it out and then
you're like okay house of blues 1200
and then you're like okay and then it's
three thousand then before you know it's
2018 and you just sold out madison
square garden
yet it doesn't feel good enough it
doesn't feel like
right you don't feel like you you made
it because then you still have this
legion of people
whether it's on the internet or
naysayers or critics
telling you why you're still not good
enough so it's this
negative thing like and this is
something that i think
people are now you know the average uh
person is experiencing via social media
because what
people in the spotlight or known people
would receive all the time
like you suck you this you that you that
now you have your average you know
seventh grade girl and someone's like
you have no tits [ __ ] and she's like
wants to kill herself like you know what
i mean
it's a real thing dude so i think people
are kind of
wising up to um a lot of what's going on
in this world and for me
i had just had enough of that because i
am i am good i'm a good guy and
i'm a talented man and i'm a good
husband and a loving father
i don't need a bunch of people who never
even met me or don't even do what i ca
can't even do what i do telling me why
it's not good enough so i kind of had
made that decision
dude there was there's so much good [ __ ]
in what you just said
and yeah i agree that there's a lot of
it that uh
is kind of
about the era that we're in right now
but at the same time
the idea of and i love the way you
described it you know like oh if i could
just be on tour and then but then i need
some money and then
sell out to roxy and then like and it's
never good enough that's
the basic premise of buddhism is that
is that the cause of all suffering is
craving right like if uh it
let's say if if you're in pain you know
if you're in pain you crave
for the pain to end but if you're having
some pleasant sensation
then you crave for it to last longer for
it to become more intense
no matter what [ __ ] position you're
in you always crave
for something something more so if it's
the roxy then
great you know no matter what we're
never going to be [ __ ] satisfied you
know and that's like uh
sort of the the the whole [ __ ] human
condition no matter how good it gets
and i was actually just sharing this
like at a group level last
night with a group of guys that i meet
with i was like man you know
my life is so [ __ ] dope my life is so
good
and yet somehow in the face of just such
great situations i can just feel twisted
up and
[ __ ] and un unsatisfied and just
like everything's not okay like i don't
know why i can't [ __ ] relax and be
like dude look at where you're at
like holy [ __ ] life is so good but
that's the human condition dude it's
crazy i think but i think that's also
yeah yes it is the human condition bro
like
it's just never gonna be nothing is ever
gonna be good enough in a way like no
matter what
so i think it's like doing our best to
be present
that's what i try to do it's like i know
you know
it's like yeah sure i want to be lovable
by my fans
but then i'm like well i'm not dropping
any rap albums so what the [ __ ] like i'm
not there's no more music
so how can i how can i still get that
and but then the real question is why do
i need that
right and this is a reason i'm also
stepping away it's like i don't need to
be validated by people i've never even
met
but then at the same time it's deeper
than validation because
it's also knowing that i've connected to
and been able to touch people
emotionally and mentally and possibly
said the words through my music that
they couldn't even conjure to
you know uh express themselves so it's
this
but then that's just me sucking my own
dick and me getting self
self gratification even though it's from
a pure place right it's just
i just [ __ ] it i'm a human i [ __ ] up
i make mistakes and uh yolo
yeah dude